while millions of us logged into  websites yesterday for all those cyber  monday deals we might have been  competing against automated shopping  bots it's automated software  relentlessly searching for and snapping  up hot consumer items in nanoseconds  before you can it's not illegal but a  huge headache for shoppers looking for  those popular items retailers face a  perfect storm the pandemic surge in  online shopping and america's supply  chain crisis  they basically go on to retail sites and  they basically scan the inventory at a  rate often more than once per second and  they effectively buy it up before the  average consumer can  bring the pandemic bot activity on  retail sites doubled